merci Laurent Laffont de nous
accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure et lui du Val-de-Marne donc
du groupe Union centriste vous présentez
ici au Sénat la commission de la culture
de l'éducation et de la communication on
va parler de votre volonté de réformer
le dieu visuel public dans quelques
instants mais d'abord l'actualité c'est
toujours ce climat social les suites du
premier mai cette nouvelle journée
annoncée par les syndicats le 6 juin
prochain est-ce que vous pensez que
d'ici là le mouvement social peut
s'essouffler
manifestement il perdure parce que pour
l'instant il y a le dialogue n'a pas été
restauré entre le gouvernement et les
syndicats et j'ajouterai aussi avec le
patronat parce que le dialogue ne doit
pas uniquement avoir lieu avec le
gouvernement mais avec le patronat moi
ce que j'entends notamment de Laurent
Berger il y a quelques instants à
travers votre reportage dans ce qui dit
il n'y a rien qui empêche de retrouver
un chemin de dialogue nous traversons je
pense plutôt sur la fin mais nous
traversons une crise sociale qui n'est
pas inédite malheureusement on en a de
manière régulière et notamment quand on
touche le système de retraite on sait
que ça provoque des réactions qui sont
compréhensibles il va falloir trouver la
porte de sortie cette porte de sortie
elle est complexe parce que il faut
restaurer un dialogue social alors que
les corps intermédiaires et en
particulier les syndicats ont été assez
malmenés ces dernières années il faut
redonner la parole et leur montrer qu'on
peut négocier discuter
des visions partagées avec eux
le travail n'a pas été fait ces derniers
mois il faut le refaire pour vous la
confiance n'est pas rompu entre les deux
qui fait les syndicats je ne sais pas on
le verra dans le temps mais en tout cas
dans ce que j'entends des paroles des
responsables syndicaux et en particulier
de la CFDT de Laurent Berger j'entends
une certaine sens des responsabilités il
met l'accent ce que vous avez illustré
dans votre portage sur la question de la
partage des valeurs on est dans une
phase économique certes complexe mais on
voit bien qu'un certain nombre de grands
groupes français ont fait des profits
très significatifs nous nous avons
souligné il y a plusieurs mois
l'importance de ces profits et le fait
que s'il est pas un retour notamment à
destination des salariés mais aussi de
la population générale ça posera un
problème social on le voit maintenant le
problème social Laurent Berger habite à
ce qui est une discussion sur ce partage
de la valeur je crois qu'il a tout à
fait il va falloir un acte fort de la
part de l'exécutif des concession faites
au syndicat après la séquence retraite
je crois qu'il faut deux choses d'abord
à l'issue de toute crise sociale il faut
une forme de mea culpa dire qu'est-ce
qui n'a pas marché si ce n'est sur
l'objet de la réforme que
personnellement j'ai voté c'est au moins
sur la méthode il faut reconnaître que
tout ce qui a été fait pour contourner
les corps intermédiaires et ben
aujourd'hui on le paye on en paye le
prix il faut restaurer cette confiance
par rapport au corps aux intermédiaires
et notamment par rapport aux syndicats
et puis la deuxième chose c'est que
quand on se met à la table de
négociation il faut avoir du grain à
moudre il faut dire ce sur quoi on est
prêt à négocier et que ces avancées
soient suffisamment significatives un
mot sur les violences qui ont eu lieu
lors du 1er mai on l'a entendu Elisabeth
bornière lors des questions d'actualité
au gouvernement à l'Assemblée condamnée
évidemment c'est violent c'est dire
qu'un nouveau palier a été franchi vous
redoutez une radicalisation du mouvement
oui malheureusement oui on le voit bien
qu'il y a des forces qui tirent vers une
radicalisation avec des scènes de
violence qui sont absolument
inacceptables et qui décèdent des
violences notamment à l'encontre des
forces de sécurité je pense que personne
aucun démocrate aucun ne peut accepter
ça et il faut le dire haut et fort et
ceux qui ne disent pas sont responsables
de ce qui se passe
notamment la France insoumise
là dessus
ne joue pas un responsable et démocrate
doivent condamner les violences qu'elles
soient et ne pas d'une certaine manière
les encourager ou les entraîner ce
qu'ils font pour vous oui parce que
notamment Jean-Luc Mélenchon n'est pas
clair dans ses propos il devrait les
condamner avec beaucoup plus de force il
y a un dossier que vous suivez entre
autres c'est la question des Jeux
Olympiques est-ce que vous redoutez des
que les syndicats fassent des actions
que certains syndicats fassent des
actions lors de ces Jeux Olympiques 2024
est perturbent les Jeux Olympiques
2024 c'est dans un peu plus d'une année
on sera je l'espère sortir de la phase
de tension sociale que nous connaissons
actuellement je pense que chacun sera
responsable chacun est conscient que cet
événement des Jeux Olympiques est un
élément majeur en terme d'image de la
France nous accueillons le monde à cette
occasion et je suis sûr que chacun saura
faire en sorte que cet événement se
passe bien se passe dans les dans les
meilleures conditions en tout cas c'est
c'est mon souhait on va continuer à
parler à de ces Jeux Olympiques pour ça
on va aller voir Jacques Pâquier bonjour
Jacques merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
rédacteurs en chef du journal du Grand
Paris on va parler des JO mais sous un
autre angle puisque des questions se
posent sur la sécurité de ces Jeux
Olympiques
absolument bonjour monsieur le sénateur
vous avez rendu en juillet dernier je
crois un rapport sur le la finale de la
Ligue des champions au Stade de France
qui s'est déroulé le 28 mai 2022 et on
se souvient avec un certain nombre
d'échauffés vous et vous écriviez que
cette événements avaient gravement
interrogé je vous cite la capacité de la
France à organiser les grands événements
sportifs alors là on va
je crois est-ce que vous êtes serein
vous faisiez une quinzaine de
préconisations vous listiez série de
dysfonctionnement vous dire on peut pas
tout mettre sur la responsabilité des
supporters de Liverpool comme certains
l'ont fait est-ce que Monsieur Lafont
vous estimez que vous avez été écouté
vous vous préconisez la meilleure
formation des stadiers une meilleure
communication entre les équipes plus de
souplesse on vous donne des signes pour
vous dire que on vous a écouté et que
tout va bien se passer pour les JO
notamment pour la cérémonie cérémonie
d'ouverture qui est inédite
la finale de la Champions League je
crois que ça a été une véritable prise
de conscience et d'une certaine manière
il y avait une forme de certitude des
autorités françaises de dire ce type
d'événement on les a déjà organisés on
sait les organiser voilà une forme de
certitude et peut-être d'arrogance dans
le comportement de certains responsables
le fait que ça ait dysfonctionné et ça
dysfonctionné à tous les étages de du
fonctionnement des des autorités
responsables à ce moment-là a été une
vraie prise de conscience que malgré
notre savoir-faire on pouvait aussi
faire des erreurs
cet événement était un événement
malheureux évidemment nous le regrettons
tous mais d'une certaine manière ça a
été un an un peu plus de deux ans avant
les Jeux Olympiques un événement qui a
permis de mobiliser chacun et de
reprendre en main tous les systèmes de
de contrôle alors est-ce que on est pour
autant totalement rassuré de nous on
nous restons vigilants en tant que les
Jeux Olympiques n'ont pas eu lieu on
peut pas dire par avance que ça pas bien
se passer je pense que l'élément phare
évidemment des futurs jeux c'est cette
cérémonie d'ouverture qui peut être un
très bel événement moi j'en suis
persuadé l'idée de le faire sur la scène
et une belle idée qui mettra en valeur
la France Paris les grands monuments le
long de la Seine qui sera très
proportionnelle qui est pas risqué c'est
dans notre tradition française on se
souvient les Jeux Olympiques
d'Albertville on se souvient de cette
cérémonie d'inauguration qui a quelque
part un peu bouleversé les cérémonies
d'une inauguration donc je pense que
qu'on est cette ambition là pour ceux de
Paris est une belle et bonne ambition
après on voit bien qu'il y a encore
certains arbitrages qui doivent être
rendus notamment sur la jauge 400500600
000 sur la façon de de filtrer les les
spectateurs qui qui viendront je pense
qu'il faut trouver le bon équilibre
entre l'ambition de cette cérémonie
d'ouverture et la nécessité d'assurer la
sécurité sur un parcours qui est
complexe on le sait mais la nécessité
d'assurer la sécurité quelque part je le
souhaite en tout cas que ça soit qu'un
mauvais événement
servent de d'une belle et une manière
quelque part la finale de la Champions
League l'année dernière a été la semaine
point mal pour un bien voilà absolument
vous avez l'impression que la France est
prête à accueillir ces Jeux Olympiques
nous le verrons l'été 2024 j'ai le
sentiment et notamment depuis un an
qu'elle se donne tous les moyens pour y
parvenir nous nous avons alerté
effectivement à travers le rapport que
nous avions fait avec le président de la
que j'avais fait avec le président de la
commission des lois
mon collègue buffet sur un certain
nombre de dysfonctionnements nous avons
été entendu sur pas mal de points il me
semble qu'il y a toujours un élément
d'incertitude qui est sur la capacité de
des sociétés de gardiennage privée à
assurer en nombre la sécurité sur
l'ensemble des sites olympiques mais
aussi sur le reste du territoire
national le recours à la à l'armée me
paraît incontournable je pense que à un
moment il faudra que l'État soit clair
sur ce cette élément là pour l'instant
il reste un peu ambigu
la question sur un autre sujet
absolument on change totalement de sujet
Laurent Lafont le Val-de-Marne que vous
représentez au Sénat est réputé pour
avoir été un pionnier du Grand Paris
Express réseau qui va bientôt voir le
jour avec les premières lignes qui sont
annoncées pour dans quelques mois et il
se trouve que on vient de d'apprendre il
y a une proposition de loi à l'Assemblée
nationale qui va dans ce sens qu'on va
étendre ces missions et qu'on va lui
confier la coordination de ce qu'on
appelle alors trivialement les réseaux
de RER métropolitain et plus
administrativement des services express
régionaux métropolitain
est-ce que vous considérez que c'est une
bonne idée monsieur le sénateur ou
est-ce que vous y voyez le risque qu'on
dévoie cette société de ses missions et
éventuellement on est l'idée de puiser
dans ces caisses
sur les conditions financières il faudra
regarder de près effectivement je trouve
que c'est une idée intéressante qui
mérite d'être gardée parce que d'abord
la SGP fait son travail même si les
réseaux n'est pas encore terminé et mise
en circulation le sentiment que ça donne
c'est qu'elle fait bien son travail donc
il y a un vrai savoir-faire qui a été
concentré à l'intérieur de cette SGP
encore une fois on réalise près 200 km
de de de réseau en quelques années dans
un contexte urbain compliqué tout le
monde ne peut pas se permettre de faire
ça et ne sait pas faire ça donc
l'idée de dire que ce savoir-faire la
qualité de ses équipes puisse servir
au-delà de la livraison du Grand Paris
Express je crois est une idée
intéressante c'est l'objet de cette
proposition de loi nous allons la
regarder avec beaucoup d'attention comme
ça personnellement je suis plutôt ouvert
à cette idée
il y a pas de risque vous êtes un expert
en vous êtes un expert en finance
publique monsieur Lafont vous n'y voyez
pas un risque qu'on vienne taper dans la
caisse si vous pouvez m'exprimer
m'excuser cette expression triviale il
faudra regarder de près parce que le
financement du Grand Paris Express comme
vous le savez bien puisque vous aussi
vous le suivez depuis de nombreuses
années c'est des recettes franciliennes
qui servent à financer
cette nouvelle ligne de métro et puis
c'est surtout un emprunt qui va
essentiellement financer en train qui va
être remboursé pendant de nombreuses
années il va falloir bien arriver à
scinder et à clairement identifier ce
qui relève du Grand Paris Express et de
ce qui pourrait être les autres missions
les autres chantiers de cette Société du
Grand Paris sur le papier comme ça cette
scission et cette cette organisation
nouvelle ne me paraît pas impossible
après il faut voir comment ça se traduit
merci
d'avoir été avec nous à la Une du
journal du Grand Paris c'est le patron
de la banque des territoires qui dresse
un bilan de son institution c'est à dire
dans le journal du Grand Paris merci
Jacques d'avoir été avec nous à très
vite on va parler de votre proposition
de voix maintenant Laurent Lafon qui
vise à réformer l'audiovisuel public on
va voir ce que contient le texte avec
Mathias Arès
bonjour Mathias bonjour Oriane et
Mathias vous allez donc nous parler de
la proposition de Laurent Lafont
absolument c'est un sujet qui revient
avec récurrence créée une grande holding
de l'audiovisuel public français à
savoir France Télévisions Radio France
France media-monde et Lina l'Institut
national de l'audiovisuel sous une seule
et grande coupole France média c'est
votre proposition Laurent la fois elle
sera examinée dans un peu plus d'un mois
maintenant l'objectif affiché exister et
peser dans les débats avant tout face à
l'état mais également face aux
partenaires privés Laurent Lafont on a
l'impression que c'est un vieux serpent
de mer cette proposition pourquoi
maintenant
effectivement c'est pas forcément une
idée nouvelle nous l'avons sorti ici au
Sénat en 2015 je crois que nous étions
les premiers aller sortir je le dis
d'autant plus modestement que ce n'était
pas moi ni Jean Raymond yvonnet qu'on
voit à l'écran mais nos prédécesseurs
Jean-Pierre Leleu et André gatolin qui
avait sorti un rapport dès 2015 l'idée
acheminer à l'époque elle était tout à
fait nouvelle l'état n'y pensait pas
enfin c'était pas dans son champ de
vision depuis il y a eu des conventions
d'objectifs et de moyens ou
systématiquement l'État a dit à
l'audiovisuel public il faut que vous
travaillez ensemble il y a eu en 2019 un
projet de loi émanant donc du
gouvernement l'occurrence du ministre de
la Culture francerie esthero prenait
cette idée malheureusement à cause de la
covid ce projet de loi a été interrompu
nous le reprenons parce qu'il y a pour
plusieurs raisons que je vais développer
dans quelques instants à travers vos
questions j'en suis sûr nécessité de de
le faire on sent surtout qu'il y a un
temps politique qui est un temps
particulier et dans lequel la question
de l'audiovisuel va se reposer pourquoi
parce que vous savez l'année dernière on
a supprimé la redevance proposition du
gouvernement il me suppression de la
redevance on vient d'apprendre il y a
quelques semaines que le système de
financement qui a été mise en place à
l'époque c'est-à-dire réaffecter une
partie de la TVA au financement de
devises publics ne pouvait pas
fonctionner au-delà de 2024 tant qu'il
n'y avait pas quelqu'un qui n'y aurait
pas une modification de la lol or pour
qui modification de la Golf c'est une
organique il faut qu'il ait l'accord du
Sénat il faut qu'il y a quand
l'Assemblée nationale bien entendu donc
il y a une discussion qui va s'engager
entre gouvernement Sénat Assemblée
nationale le Sénat majorité sénatoriale
à travers la PPL que j'ai déposé apporte
la pierre à l'édifice et son élément de
comment dirais-je de discussion avec les
deux autres partenaires mais ça veut
dire que clairement il y a des
inquiétudes sur le financement de Dieu
visuel public aujourd'hui pour vous bien
sûr bien sûr il y a des inquiétudes dans
la mesure où le système qui a été mis en
place l'année dernière la même époque il
y a un peu moins d'un an ne peut pas
fonctionner tant qu'il n'y a pas
modification de la Golf donc il faut
modifier la lol question volontairement
provocatrice qu'est-ce qui distingue
votre projet aujourd'hui de ce qui a pu
un jour être l'ORTF
ces deux choses de nature totalement
différentes le RTF c'était un système de
contrôle de l'audiovisuel public là
c'est pas un système de de contrôle par
l'État c'est un système de coordination
et de définition stratégique commune
entre les différentes acteurs entre les
quatre entités que vous avez cité c'est
un outil de pilotage et économique et
stratégique pour dire quels sont les
investissements stratégiques qui doivent
être réalisés comment on aborde la
question du numérique comment on aborde
la question de l'intelligence
artificielle comment on aborde la
question de la télévision connectée on
sait que ce paysage est en pleine
évolution il y a nécessité d'avoir un
outil plus fonctionnel opérationnel
réactif c'est ça nous proposons on va en
parler du numérique dans quelques
secondes juste pour qu'on comprenne bien
quelle différence entre la holding que
vous proposez une fusion
la fusion c'est que on regroupe toutes
les entités les quatre entités dans une
seule et même entité c'est un schéma que
moi je trouve intéressant mais qui est
extrêmement complexe c'est à dire qu'il
faut revoir tous les statuts des tous
les contrats des agents les uniformiser
remettre en question d'une certaine
manière l'histoire de ces sociétés leur
culture les spécificités entre le monde
de l'audio le monde de
la télévision on sait que c'est très
compliqué est-ce que la holding a
vocation aboutir à la fusion ça c'est
l'avenir qui dira et c'est la façon dont
cette holding est évoluera à ce stade
c'est pas ce que nous écrivons et ce que
nous disons mais l'avenir le dire en
tout cas l'idée c'est que nous ayons un
outil relativement qui peut être
relativement mis en oeuvre puisque au
1er janvier 2024 on est inscrivait
inscrit dans la PPL je vais l'inscrire à
la PPL ça pourrait être fait et dès lors
il y aura je pense une ligne un objectif
qui ça sera clairement affichée pour
l'ensemble des responsables de cette
audiovisée publique Laurent Lafon
parlait du numérique c'est l'un des
premiers arguments cette transition
numérique
de arte par exemple qui a surbrassé plus
rapidement le virage numérique reste du
service public audiovisuel c'est l'un de
vos arguments car là encore il s'agit de
peser dans les nouveaux rapports de
force de l'audiovisuel et notamment face
au plateformes américaines comme
l'explique Jean Raymond Hugonnet
sénateur LR qui pourrait être peut-être
votre premier cosignataire
l'arme supplémentaire évidente déjà
c'est sur le numérique et l'intelligence
artificielle pensez-vous que des entités
séparées travaillant séparément peuvent
aboutir à quelque chose forcément
efficace mais surtout de rapides
aujourd'hui ne serait-ce que pouvoir
regrouper cette intelligence
artificielle et ce travail sur le
numérique donnerait plus de puissance
c'est déjà un élément forcément
déterminant avec son fonctionnement que
certains qualifient de fonctionnement en
silo est-ce que l'audiovisuel public
souffre d'une perte d'énergie d'économie
ou de manque à gagner tout simplement
oui absolument ce sont des entreprises
certes sur des entreprises publiques
mais ce sont des entreprises et les
entreprises dans un secteur économique
extrêmement concurrentiel et c'est le
cas leurs concurrents c'est plus TF1
c'est plus M6 c'est Netflix et Amazon
c'est des sociétés qui fonctionnent avec
une vitesse une rapidité etc sur lequel
on est bien obligé de s'adapter et c'est
ça que nous disons et vraiment je
connais l'illustre à travers les enjeux
en termes de numérique en termes
d'intelligence artificielle le temps
administratif ne correspond pas au temps
économique dans lequel sont ces
entreprises et il faut à travers cette
nouvelle structure les accompagner les
aider il y a un vrai enjeu de
souveraineté audiovisuel qui se pose
aujourd'hui Mathias répondent les
opposants à ce projet alors on sait
Delphine Ernotte présidente de France
Télévisions plutôt favorable si il
veille de Radio France plutôt contre
alors il y a déjà des atermoiements de
rapprochement alors pas de fusion
attention entre France Bleu et France 3
par exemple le SNJ d'ailleurs de Radio
France par le là d'un projet
inacceptable ce qui inquiète certains
sur ce sujet c'est la centralisation
l'uniformisation de médias dit
complémentaires avec des lignes
éditoriales différentes et la peur d'une
perte d'indépendance pour quelques
économies de bout de ficelle ce sont les
mots de Xavier Couture ancien numéro 2
de France Télévisions par ailleurs on
parle là d'un chantier juridique
faramineux pour certains qui pourraient
prendre plusieurs plusieurs années
plusieurs années selon des sociétés de
conseils en audiovisuel alors pour
autant Laurent Lafont votre ambition
dans ce texte c'est de voir naître cette
holding au 1er janvier vous le disiez
tout à l'heure comment il parvenir
écoutez c'est 9 articles de loi modifier
c'est la PPN que j'ai présenté hier non
juridiquement la chose est assez facile
à faire d'ailleurs je le dis en toute
honnêteté simplicité je me suis beaucoup
inspiré du projet de Loire ister qui a
été déposé commencé d'être débattue à
l'Assemblée nationale en 2019 donc
juridiquement crée une holding c'est
assez simple très honnêtement on n'est
pas innovant on croit toujours quand on
touche aux structures publiques qu'on
crée quelque chose de génial et
d'innovant dans le secteur privé créer
une ligne ça se fait en quelques
semaines et en quelques mois donc ne
croyons pas qu'on est en train de
construire un monstre etc c'est une
structure légère c'est 20 30 personnes
qui vont travailler au niveau de cette
holding le texte de idée là on va le en
débattre nous au Sénat nous avons oui
mi-juin nous avons aussi des échanges
avec nos collègues de l'Assemblée
nationale
puisqu'il y a une mission d'information
qui a été lancée maintenant il y a
plusieurs mois sur l'édition du service
public moi je suis en contact avec
Quentin bataillon qui est
le rapporteur et nous travaillons aussi
avec Jean-Jacques Gauthier Jean Raymond
Hugonnet sur ces sur ces sujets ce que
je constate c'est que ils arrivent aussi
à cette conclusion apparemment en tout
cas quand un bataillon l'a dit hier aux
échos de la nécessité de de faire
optimiste sur la navette parlementaire
le texte sera repris à l'Assemblée
nous verrons je voudrais pas préjugé des
résultats mais en tout cas pour
l'instant il y a une convergence et je
souhaite que cette convergence quelque
part c'était quelque chose d'un peu
innovant c'est à dire que les deux
chambres dans un contexte politique
particulier on le souhaite en tout cas
les les les les parlementaires qui
travaillent sur ces sujets on le
souhaite d'avancer ensemble c'est très
bien par mi les inquiétudes il y a aussi
la question de l'emploi est-ce que la
création d'une holding ça signifie des
suppressions de poste dans ces groupes
aux événements sportifs pour les
téléspectateurs aujourd'hui ça coûte
souvent cher d'avoir accès aux
événements sportifs rien qu'aux match de
foot il faut avoir plusieurs abonnements
à différentes chaînes est-ce qu'il y a
une injustice sociale aujourd'hui dans
le fait de pouvoir regarder du sport à
la télé oui de plus en plus c'est ça les
gens n'en sont pas forcément conscients
c'est-à-dire que nous sommes encore dans
l'idée de dire on va pouvoir regarder le
Tour de France Roland Garros c'est les
équipes les matchs de l'équipe de France
de football ou de rugby sur le service
public et donc on voit bien que ça se
passe plus comme ça et ça n'est pas fini
ça va être ça va aller en section cette
privatisation d'une certaine manière des
grands événements sportifs et notre
cadre juridique sur les événements
d'importance majeurs est assez fragile
assez faible on l'a vu l'année dernière
à travers Roland Garros ou Amazon a
récupéré une partie des droits et le
match Nadal Djokovic qui était un des
principaux matchs de cette de ce et
voilà était décalé à le soir pour passer
sur Amazon et pas sur France Télévision
il y a un semble tout aussi similaire
sur le tournoi des destinations en rugby
ou probablement il va y avoir un
allotissement et une possibilité que les
matchs de l'équipe de France reste sur
France Télévisions mais que le reste
passe sur une autre chaîne évidemment
dans ces cas-là France Télévision est
aux concurrence avec qui c'est pas avec
M6 et TF1 un peu mais c'est surtout avec
Amazon avec Netflix avec ses grandes
sociétés américaines dont la puissance
financière est considérable et s'ils
veulent obtenir des droits il les
obtiendront justement parce que ils ont
cette masse financière importante il
nous estime enfin nous avons estimé que
militaire important que le législateur
prennent position et à travers la loi
c'est notre outil
protège les la souveraineté de de d'un
certain nombre d'acteurs français et
permettent justement que le plus grand
nombre est accès à ces grands événements
sportifs un dernier sujet dans votre
texte en quelques mots vous souhaitez
aussi rééquilibrer le partage de la
valeur entre les distributeurs et les
producteurs ayant des équilibre
aujourd'hui oui très clairement d'abord
nous avons un système de financement de
la production cinématographique
audiovisuel qui est performant et c'est
extrêmement important que nous soyons
créateurs de ce point de vue là d'un
certain nombre d'émissions de films de
Téléfilm je crois que le problème
actuellement on n'est pas un problème de
financement de ce secteur il y a des des
financements publics ou à travers les
les différentes éditeurs le problème est
acquisition de un problème de partage de
la valeur entre ceux qui les ont
financés et notamment évidemment les les
chaînes et les sociétés de production je
vais vous citer un chiffre pour
illustrer France Télévisions finances
chaque année près de 520 millions de de
production indépendante
et que ce soit pour la télévision pour
le cinéma ils n'en tire que 10 millions
de revenus annuels commercialisation
chaque année donc voyez bien que il y a
un problème de retour sur
l'investissement du point de vue des
éditeurs et ce qu'on demande juste c'est
qu'il y a un rééquilibrage qui est une
renégociation entre producteurs et les
différentes chaînes françaises et le
texte sera donc examiné la semaine du 12
juin on en parlera évidemment dans cette
émission merci Mathias et merci Laurent
Laffont d'avoir été notre invité pendant
cette première demeure dans 20 minutes
dans le club des territoires débat sur
le projet d'autoroute entre Castres et
Toulouse les travaux ont commencé mais
le projet est toujours contesté
reportage sur place et débat entre de
sénateurs sur ce plateau dans 20 minutes
d'abord on accueille notre prochaine
invité Christophe Béchu nous rejoint